Okay,
as promised, we are back.
Oops.
Where's the thing?
There.
We're good.
Wars is just like one of those examples
of a a project that was taken like 80%
of the way there, but then
like ended up not getting used super
often because of
some very very small things that could
have been avoided.
So, this one's worth spending a little
time.
Make sure this is actually
Yeah, it's a clean port.
Yeah, Impulse Wars is annoying because
it it's the only end where the author
just insisted on having a CMake system
and it was always a pain because of
that. And the guy said like, "Oh, well,
you could just use shemake for all your
M's." But like, no, dude. Like why the
hell should we need cmake for all the
M's when it's literally like a one line
with clanganger GCC for everything else.
I reviewed this, right? This was clean.
Simple and
Oh, dude. I've been like going on 80 for
years. I'm so old.
MIT
uh Stanford undergrad MIT for PhD.
My thesis was on massively multi-agent
simulation and intelligence.
Essentially, what if Runescapes or World
of Warcraft but RL?
What does that mean for learning? What
does that mean for infrastructure? What
does that mean for what we can discover?
What does that mean for how we design
our approaches?
And uh now I'm essentially taking all
that information from making RL work on
really crazy problems
and using it to make RL work just about
everywhere and be very very fast.
contest. This one's weird. I haven't
reviewed this one.
I definitely don't want to be working
for any companies. Thank you very much.
I have my own.
Buffer is a small private RL lab
and uh I pretty much just want to be
left to my own devices to make
as large of breakthroughs as I can with
a small team.
Oh, it is a tower defense. That's weird.
I didn't realize that whatsoever.
This really didn't look like a tower
defense to me
on a big background.
I make my own tech syrup. Well, I mean,
you should start from learning some
things, right? If you're second year in
CS, the best piece of guidance I can
give you,
if you go to my X page here
on a browser that's logged in, hang on.
So look, if you go over here to the
articles tab, this is all my research,
but then also
this article right here.
This is your best friend.
This is like how to actually learn core
tech fundamentals that matter
and how to not get extract distracted by
dumb
Why do I stream these? Hold myself
accountable. No, not remotely to
entertain myself for the most part. And
uh because all my stuff is open source,
the community tends to find it helpful
because let's say that you're building
an environment for Puffer or trying to
use Puffer on something. It's all like
open source, right? Um what's easier,
right? Like trying to figure out who the
heck you can ask to like figure out how
this crazy library works or oh the guy
that built its nuts and just streams dev
constantly.
makes it pretty easy, right?
And because of streaming and because of
all the new people that have gotten into
Puffer, because of this, we've gotten
tens of thousands of lines of PRs of new
environments and quite a bit of open
source contribution to the library
that's been very helpful.
Huh.
Interesting.
How's the code quality here? It looks
cool.
What internship have you worked for?
I haven't taken any in a while.
I started my PhD work originally at
OpenAI like in 2018 or something. It was
a really cool place back then. Not so
much anymore.
Wait, I'm trying to see how competent
the person who did this was.
Decent.
Not great.
But decent
some sort of newbie
newbie things.
He intentionally do that.
What are your thoughts on using AI to
code? I hate it.
It's like honestly pretty annoying,
but I use it a lot for like maintenance
and stuff.
Um, oh yeah, and for you for uh for
people who are relatively new to CS, the
last thing you need to be doing is doing
like super heavy AI dev. You need to go
like write some C by hand, my friend.
I genuinely can't tell at a glance how
bloated this thing is.
Primary language
see if I can.
I really like C.
But for Puffer, it's a mix of C and CUDA
or the noob things.
Oh, I mean, I'm just like looking at
stuff like having gigantic there just
like a lot of tells. Um like just having
gigantic like super deeply nested code
with ifs where you could like short
circuit early.
Um, having like crazy super long lines
for like stuff that could obviously very
easily be split out. Um, I also I look
for like AI like things that look really
heavily AI gen. I don't see any of that
here. I think this PR was from before
people were widely using AI models for
coding. I don't uh this okay this is AI
gen but this is AI gen from the the port
not from the original code
I mostly like if I'm just skimming that
quickly though I'm pretty much just
looking at like basic control flow
pattern messups.
What am I doing now? So this is the uh
pre-release phase let's call it for
Puffer 5.0. So, we have a big release
coming out soon, right? And I'm pulling
in now like 15ish new environments
written by contributors. That's a lot of
code to triage and a lot of it is uh
targeted at an old version of Puffer and
needs to be upgraded to our latest API
and a lot of it has like subtle bugs.
So, I'm essentially semi-automatically
going through and having Grock look for
all the patterns I know for like common
errors that people make. Um, I'm going
through and looking for common patterns
that I know LLM screw up and making sure
that the LLM hasn't messed up all the
nice code. And I also have this this
thing has access to a 8GPU box. So, I'm
also having this thing orchestrate some
test runs to make sure that everything
is training correctly and building new
binaries for our website. So whole bunch
of stuff. Um, but this is considered for
me this is like generally pretty brain
dead easy routine work. Um, the stuff
that's a lot more interesting is like
the detailed research work that I do or
the heavy performance engineering that I
do for the core of Puffer.
Those tend to be the more interesting
sessions. This weekend, since I have the
weekend to myself and we're very close
to release, I'm kind of just marathon
streaming until I have the entire
pre-release done, which is why I'm
pulling a lot of hours.
I think we can get it all done this
weekend, though. I think we can get it
all done.
When did I start coding? What age? I
like 11 or 12.
Maybe 13 or 14. Actually making some
real things. And then probably like 16
before anything that I wrote wasn't
complete and utter crap.
Long-term vision for Puffer. We are
going to make reinforcement learning
sane, stable, and consistent. It is
going to be a mature area of AI that
just works out of the box on a huge
range of problems and is so fast that
you can train models for specific tasks
at home on a single GPU.
We're actually most of the way there.
Like I think we're like probably 75% of
the way there actually. I've been
working on this for three years. I think
basically we have it within the next
year.
I can show the codebase real quick.
Check this out. So this is the highest
performance reinforcement learning
codebase in existence by about three
orders of magnitude
as of well ignore this. This is this is
getting deleted but and this is also 400
lines of LLM bloat that I have to
delete. Stupid LLMs. Um, so this is only
10k lines. Like the entire core I it
took a long time to get it to be this
short. It's only 10k lines. The core
training and everything, no pietorch,
everything from scratch in cuda c is
only 5k lines. It's this puffl file and
then this algo file. And then we have
our own visualization toolkit which is
one file,600 lines. We have our own CPU
eval infrastructure. This is the thing
the LLM loaded. It should only be about
a thousand lines. And then we have our
own envi. And we have uh protein, which
is our hyperp sweeps. Pretty much
everything.
How many hours do I code per week? Like
I don't know, anywhere from 20 to 90.
[laughter] It really depends, man.
But yeah, I mean, if you're looking to
learn, we've literally had high school
students contribute environments to
Puffer. Obviously, the high end of all
the research stuff that we do takes
quite a bit of experience to get into,
but honestly, like programming
reinforcement learning environments is
kind of just like doing low-level game
development. Um, you can make something
meaningful in only a couple hundred
lines of code and you can train it at
home.
good way to learn some low-level dev.
It's a good way to get some exposure to
RL. And some of the environments even
end up being directly useful in
research. Believe it or not, it's
actually pretty hard to anticipate
upfront the uh the types of environments
that are going to be very helpful.
Getting into Fang,
I uh I think you might end up being a
little bit disappointed. Um,
you can definitely do that just by like
conventional computer science education
and learning how to prep for interviews
and stuff, but like the average Fang
employee is an absolutely terrible
engineer.
Like I wouldn't even want the average
Fang engineer touching our code base.
Um, let alone be like, you know,
actually trying to be one of the major
people doing anything.
Big tech in general is just very very
low quality. And
typically small teams within big
companies and then specific startups um
tend to be much better.
How much am I coding versus how much the
agent do? All right. This is always the
question that new people ask. Like look
this is maintenance work. Okay, I wrote
this env here by hand in like two or
three hours. And this env is like our
minimal de uh demonstration en that we
use. Do I have a demo of it? No, I
don't. This is an even simpler one. I
It's basically a fancier version of this
where RL agents go around and eat
targets and stuff. Um
you can write you can get an agent to do
the same thing, but it'll write much
much worse code. So, I tend to do pretty
much all the sim dev pretty much by
hand. Um, core infrastructure stuff,
it's mixed.
Like the very important bits I end up
doing by hand. Things that are less
important or experimental, I will
sometimes prototype with an agent and
then very very heavily refactor.
My general take though is that the the
LLMs write absolutely terrible code, but
that doesn't mean that they're not
useful.
But you get the idea of mang at the
point as we're talking about big tech.
Yeah, I know the companies like
even those are overrated for enjoyment
and work.
Like all of those people have like all
those companies have some good people
somewhere, but if you're just looking at
like the average person on your team if
you just join, they will be incredibly
stupid.
and very bad at programming.
Open AAI actually, funny enough, um when
I was there and it was only a 100
people, it was by far the best place
I've ever worked. Like it made the
average person at Stanford and the
average person at MIT look like a
complete imbecile. But that's when it
was 100 people. You don't grow to be a
thousand people and keep that talent
density. Like there aren't any companies
with a thousand people where everyone's
just smart. You can't find that many
smart people in one place,
Nex.js and Java. uh literally teaches
you negative programming. Do not touch
those.
I learned Java as my first real
programming language and it literally
took me years to unlearn the garbage
that that teaches you.
Become good.
No, it's not natural talent. I did it
for like freaking 15 years and very very
slowly over time like I learned that a
lot of the things that are typically
taught about how to program inevitably
lead to pain and suffering and you
writing terrible code that you have to
deal with. Um
and then eventually you find like people
actually writing good stuff and you see
that things are done very differently.
Not everyone can be an ML.
Everyone can be ML.
So
doesn't mean I I like I can't think of a
single project that I'd ever say, "Ah,
yes, Java. That's what we should use for
this."
Like, you know, Java, the reason Java
got so popular in the first place, it
was because it was the first mass
marketed programming language. It was
mostly advertising money.
language I recommend if you're learning
if you are early on learning to program
I would highly recommend you learn C
because the thing is
when you understand low-level
programming like every other language
feature that exists you can understand
how it works and how you would implement
it and you can actually think of whether
that language feature is even something
that you need
like oh concurrency like well I could
implement my own and most of the time I
don't actually even want it when people
would be using
key factor hierarchical RL or stick with
uh hey welcome HRL typically just
doesn't work unfortunately
I am not aware of any HRL approaches
that actually do what is advertised it's
mostly results just being inflated on
paper that don't generalize
um there are a couple of architectures
that I have wanted to try out mostly
like um long and short time horizon
stacked recurrent nets,
but I think the heavier algo changes
that I've seen
definitely don't work
unfortunately.
I know there's a lot of lit on the
topic, but it's this is true of a lot of
areas of RL
Z is not useful.
[laughter]
Oh my gosh, guy. You don't like the
funny thing is I like people will send
me crap in Python. It will I will write
it in C. It will be the exact same
amount of code is what they send me and
mine will run a thousandx faster.
I'm not going to try to be mean here and
I'm not going to argue with you, but
there's seriously some stuff you've got
to reconsider.
I probably wouldn't have listened to me
when I first started either, but like if
I had listened it would have saved me
many, many years.
If you want the proof, just look at some
of the stuff I've built and look how
compact and efficient it is and think
how the hell you would do that in any
like how the hell you would do that in
any other language.
in RL specifically? It's mostly dried up
to be honest with you. Um, Jacob
Forers's lab still has some good stuff
coming out. Eugene Vaninsk's lab still
has some stuff coming out. Um, in
robotics specifically, there's still a
couple good labs, not so much in general
RL.
But our whole field's gotten brain
drained by all the LLM companies,
unfortunately. Like all the people that
I used to really respect in RL, they're
no longer doing RL, which sucks.
It really sucks.
industry might have gone. See, that's
kind of weird. I When was that? Because
like there's zero money right now in RL.
Well, not zero. Like I Puffer is still
profitable. We have clients and such,
but compared to language models, it's so
so so little. And it actually works now
is the crazy thing. Like we can spin up
new Sims on new problems for people in a
period of weeks. and we can train them
at the scale of hundreds of billions of
steps quite easily.
So stuff actually does work now. It just
turns out that the approach that was
being used back when RL was in vogue um
it was very heavily focused on
algorithms and algorithmic innovations
to the detriment of infrastructure.
six months ago.
Nah, he's wrong. Look, Ila's a very very
smart guy. Um,
you could ve you can tell that when he
was at Open AI, like he was like one of
the coolest people to talk to at OpenAI.
Honestly,
I remember one day he asked me like,
"What do you think about Alec Radford's
like language model? What do you think
about this GP like this transformer
thing and compression as an objective
for intelligence?" And I remember
telling him that I think it's great. I
think it'll go very far, but I think
you're still going to need RL. You need
interactivity.
And now they're doing RL on language
models, right? But it's very, very weak
RL and it's very slow.
I hope he does well as well. I hope he
does well, too. I hope he's doing
something really cool there.
Oh, of course we're using standard lib.
Wait, are we
I'm wondering if without the allocations
if it's still there.
Oh, Randar. Duh.
Jeepa. Um, maybe.
My general take on world models is like
they're cool. I don't think they're cool
for in the loop RL for the type of stuff
I do. Um the best known paper in that
space is borderline fraud. Not jeepa
other one. Um
and they're very very slow and
fundamentally it seems like you can't
fix that
like fast onpl seems to be the thing
that works.
I did fix double pendulums. I haven't
actually looked at it, but it seems we
have uh we have like a one a score of
one.
I did pull your ch your your fix in.
Thank you.
No, it's totally orthogonal. I mean,
maybe little bits of what I do could to
be fair, but like the problem with um
LLM RL is they just they don't train
value functions. They can't. It's
basically like RL with an utterly stupid
action space. And the algorithms that
they're coming up with to try to get
around that are so horrendously
inefficient. They're just essentially
lighting money on fire at a crazy rate
to try to force it to work.
positive arithmetic. I don't know
anything about that.
Hardware vendor should Yeah. Yeah.
That's kind of like outside of my
domain.
I think what's going to happen is we're
going to turn this into a selfplay end,
but not yet.
So that one we know
net hack
net hack we can pull in Finn's latest
I I don't know anything like that seems
that sounds sounds like a long shot to
me.
There's definitely like hardware like
specific hardware stuff you can do.
I don't think that there's much you can
do on general matrix multiplies though.
What's been done today? Jess, we've got
all the environments running.
and stable with demos on the website or
at the local build of the website and
I've gone through
a little over half of them so far for
cleanups to make sure LLM has not just
slopped them totally
with uh with any of the binding
integration changes. I have a few
categories of things left to finish,
like better rendering for turn-based
games,
but overall, I'd say it's going pretty
well.
How was chess?
Honestly, I just saw the big file. I
took a quick skim, said like that's way
higher quality code than all the other
I'm dealing with right now and
I just left it as is.
I just essentially made sure we didn't
make a mess of it.
Thanks.
Yeah. Also, we're going to have MOA for
selfplay, too. So, we have a lot of
selfplay M that we can mess with, right?
Open source is a big threat.
I'd certainly hope so.
Oh, oops. You thought that you were
going to make all the money in the world
and have everybody pay you for the AI.
Now it's free. Haha.
That sounds pretty nice to me.
It's mainly trying to cram enough lemon
to everything. Jess
getting tired tonight.
I done a research.
Um,
engineering is a very very powerful tool
for research
as is science.
There are too many people that just want
to do the science or just want to do
their
you need to do what is needed to solve
the problem you care about.
You can't be married to an approach.
You have to be married to the outcome
read my article,
like read my article and do projects.
I basically did speedrun becoming a good
engineer after I finished my PhD, to be
honest. Like I could already write code
that would be much better than the
majority of what you'd see in industry.
Um, but like all the low-level dev,
that's all new. That's all in the past 3
years. like it was I was pretty much
already very much at home because I'd
already spent a very long amount of time
just like trying to figure out how to
write better code and understanding all
the possible design trade-offs of
different approaches. So like from that
sense it was pretty natural to me. Um
and it really didn't feel hard to like
relearn systems. It it felt like very
straightforward and it felt freeing if
anything.
Bradford was a bad engineer.
I think he would agree with that
statement as well. He did all his stuff
out of out of notebooks. I remember that
he like he was very good at
counteracting it though. He would like
throw away all of his code and just
write everything from scratch every
project. So he could never accumulate a
whole bunch of tech debt. It was just a
really good scientist, right? He was the
like for every rule there's an
exception. Radford was a great guy. I
have like basically only good things to
say about him.
research. I get worried of what I could
be reading.
Yeah, research. The problem is that a
lot of the lit is very low quality, even
from people that should know better. Uh,
this is in my article as well. So, if
you're curious about that, read my
article. [laughter]
Uh,
not being in a frontier.
Well, I'm motivated by money. I'm just
not only motivated by money.
I figure I can make money anyways. And
what I'm doing, it's far more important.
It's far more important that this exists
than that they have one additional
person at a giant company where it's
already impossible to do anything.
Also, Puffer is a frontier company. We
make puffer lip.
my guide to programming in ML. It's my
It's my highest rated piece of content.
We're tried that since Look, I'm in a
place where like
the worst thing that can happen at the
moment is that like I have to go join a
company or join some other startup or
whatever, which seems very unlikely to
me. Like we have clients.
I'm barely putting any time into like
actively expanding the business side. I
mostly do the research. The tech is
getting better at a ridiculously fast
rate.
So, in my mind, there's really not any
risk associated with doing what I'm
doing.
Go found a startup. That's what I'm
doing, man. Buffer is a company. Our
stuff's open source, but they're still a
company.
Yeah. So, PhD, I never try to convince
anybody to do a PhD. Um, you really only
should be doing a PhD if you know that
you want to do a PhD.
Like there are a lot of strings that
come with doing uh stuff in academia.
You kind of have to like the whole
conference and publishing system or at
least be able to stay sane while dealing
with it because it's really at
times. Um
academia is not all that open-minded.
They have a very specific idea of what
they consider to be the way that you
make progress.
I'm having much much more fun now doing
stuff on my own.
Uh why Grock? For like the 20th time
today, it's faster than the other
models. That's all it is. It's faster.
Pulling a net hack. I should have had
this in sub agent.
Oops.
I have to take a I have to take a call
real quick. I will be back in like five
minutes. One sec here.
We'll be back in like five minutes.
Uh and we will continue.
We will continue on in a second.
I just saw like a notification on the
side. Hang on.
I missed something important.
One moment.
Okay.
All right. We're good. We're good.
Uh,
I watched your PhD thesis defense two
years ago.
That's crazy. Atari part of it. Throw it
back the memory. Atari is not the world.
Yeah. Well, we solved breakout in under
a second now. So, I think it's a little
more obvious
that it's it's not that hard.
Visor
MIT PhD
self knowledge.
Yeah. You know, [clears throat]
I kind of have a a little bit of a
balanced take on that. It's like on one
sense, I kind of just want the knowledge
to exist and be used broadly. I'd like
to make some money off of it in the
process as well, but not by keeping it
behind closed doors.
joining a lab. Nope. Puffer is a lab.
The puffer AI lab.
Well,
that's fine.
air source
after 2 years.
The thing is I don't think any of the
the labs are actually going to obey like
people don't obey licenses like that
anyways.
So basically all you're saying is that
now you want to have a bunch of lawyers
on staff to like enforce your or
whatever.
The stuff is either closed or it's open.
Like I guarantee you if I were to talk
to like some of the customers I have,
right, I talk to them and say they say
like, "Oh, it's open source." So like,
you know, what do you do if it's open
source? And I say, "Oh, well, look, we
made the software. We know what's coming
next. We're really good at applying it.
we are the ones who built it after all.
It's a pretty easy sell. But like if it
were open source but licensed and say,
"Well, you need to hire us because of
the license." They're just going to get
really quiet and know like, "Well, we're
just going to, you know, have an LLM
port it internally or whatever and we'll
use that."
Like, screw that. It's open or it's
closed. End of story.
This is good.
That's good.
How'd you connect with NYU to
collaborate? I talked with Eugene at a
conference
at Nurups a few years ago and I saw this
sim and I was like, you know, we could
make that fast.
Material science. Yeah, I started trying
to bind lamps for that a while ago and
it sort of became obvious that uh it was
going to take a lot more work like
deeper work with the material science
packages because they're really not
built for it.
contributions. Yeah. Where do you think
all these environments come from? The
majority of them are from contributors.
This is in 40. And we have like another
15 or 20 of them that we're adding to
5o.
They're pretty cool. This is by an
undergrad.
This was so good that I had to take him
as an intern.
can play Rocket League. You definitely
can. That has been done before. Um, you
can probably get it to work much faster
though than uh existing approaches
because I think that they just bind the
actual game which is really Hello.
Oh, you don't have to train it on
correct play.
You just train it on sim and the sim
goes very fast.
Like do you understand the amount of
data that we can generate? You can
literally train on a month worth of
games per second for a lot of our Sims.
It's an utterly stupid amount of data.
Buffer is really fast.
C computer the brain parts on a what?
E L I don't know what that
code deployable.
I have no idea what that I have I don't
know anything about that, man. I'm
sorry. I can't tell you
Objectives material sigh
are the material science m to science
and materials of course
I don't know optimize some properties
are given a configuration
I have a feeling puffer will science
many materials All right.
Discover new materials. That sure that
would be great. I like to discover many
materials.
interface problem.
You can definitely get even like you
don't even need a you don't need a big
model to be able to move a mouse around.
Actually, there's this N that we made
that's just like an aim like an aim
booster env. You can totally train a
little agent to basically have perfect
control over a mouse in only a few
seconds.
I used to think that that one was hard,
but it's really not.
The annoying thing about um using a
mouse is actually like having to
simulate a screen because you don't want
to do the calcs on rendered space, you
know? You want to do it like the end
somehow is defined on screen space but
not rendered.
without the intelligent thought.
That's most people, my guy.
connect via APIs. Yeah, exactly. So,
that's the real question, Crit. Um,
I don't think that we want the stupid
AIs to be using our interfaces in the
first place. It's incredibly
inefficient.
We kind of just did the aim boost end
because it was a funny thing to
Oh Jesus. W the guard. It actually
understood that. That's funny.
I just I'm sorry. I'm taking a couple
extra minutes to finish this correctly
cuz I don't want this messing up my
really nice.
I I don't like this messing up my nice
thing.
some open source ML stuff
improv for once. Depends what you're
working on. We do have a lot of fancy
kernel code.
Not that fancy, but
there's kernel code.
Does it run? No, you uh as the new
versions of Puffer, you cannot run
training on Apple Silicon. It's CUDA
specific. That said, you can spin
yourself up an instance on vast for like
10 cents an hour with a decent GPU.
Yeah, don't buy a GPU. Just like
literally 10 cents an hour on Vast will
get you something good enough way better
than you could ever do on Apple silicon.
in puffer 5 we are making nice CPU eval
infrastructure. So if you train your
policies on um if you train your
policies on like a vast instance you
will be able to eval and render them
locally. That is one of the things that
we added in 50 is very nice CPU
evaluation.
adverts pop up everywhere.
So, I have my Twitch set to the minimum
possible number of ads that it lets you
set, which is 30 uh 30 seconds an hour.
You can drop prime subs if you have
them. That'll disable them on my channel
fully, but that's basically it. I I
cannot disable ads for users.
How's it been going?
Hey, Weston.
Good to see you, man.
We are almost to puffer 5.0.
Almost to puffer five.
It's entirely cudy now. Under 10,000
lines. Well, it will be for release.
Under 10k lines of CUD to C,
super compact, no Python,
If I find out something might need weeks
of training.
Uh, so weeks of training is normal if
you're not using Puffer Lib. Our stuff
is fast. So, no, no weeks of training.
That's not me being arrogant either.
It's literally like a thousandx faster.
Uh, so it's weird. The Apple silicon
stuff is really weird because it's like
you can kind of do really slow shitty
inference on it at like a weirdly good
price point um because of the memory.
Yeah, that doesn't mean that it's good
compute though. It's really jank.
Rock is faster.
2 M's from 3 0 to 40. Wait, which two
were yours? I think I did it for you.
I think I did it for you, man. Where's
Weston on here?
Wait, why are you not on here?
Bro, if you PRD your thing, I would I'd
have your name on here.
All right. Which one was yours? Remind
me.
Cuz I bet you that I've already ported
it up to 50. And you should just PR your
name to the website so I can include you
guys hiring not now new grad. Um we're
not really hiring full-time just
randomly
because we're like we don't take
funding. We're bootstrapped. So we do we
are planning to expand but like slowly
and uh as we're getting more sustainable
clients and stuff
and it will probably mostly start with
people from the community who've been
doing like who've actually been doing
tons of good RL work around
like Spencer for instance who's now
working with me on this full-time. He
literally just started making puff rams
and didn't stop and then started
contributing to core and then all the
like the contract stuff and etc etc
rlk
uh it's more just like really really
high perf training and infrared and
stuff.
I don't know. You can clone it and try
it out.
Weston, which one was your end? Please
remind me
cuz I probably have a cool demo to show
you.
Give me a triple triad
Mexican train. I can't remember which I
PRD.
I don't think you PR all of them cuz I
went through and I merged a whole bunch
of enms in and I don't remember any of
those.
Would I say less? No.
Buffer is a frontier lab by the way.
Name one other place with with RL tech
this good. Nobody
twerson Frontier lab. Still a Frontier
Lab.
You have subs on YouTube. Does YouTube
even have subs
for that answer? You don't have to give
me money, man. It's uh we're chill. I
don't I don't really care to monetize my
viewers. Like the business side of
Puffer is building high perf Sims and RL
integrations for uh large companies.
Do I go to conferences?
You know, RLC is actually happening
right now, and I was thinking about
going, but I really couldn't be
bothered.
I kind of figured I would just jam dev
this weekend instead and get our
pre-release Done.
got to get that done. PR triple triad
change 40 has triple P pointers.
I mean, point me at the stuff, man. Just
put in the Discord or whatever and I'll
merge them.
If you have any new M's as well, I will
definitely uh pull some in. We have like
50 M's now.
Twitch subs don't show up on the stream.
My bad. Thank you very much, my friend.
Enjoy your ad previewing.
Well, it's cuz I'm not just on Twitch,
right? I'm like multistreamed.
Became video editor for AI Tango. Oh,
cool.
stuff looked interesting.
I kind of decided that offpaul was just
not going to scale reasonably
with uh with data. The offpaul
algorithms just stack so many damn
tricks and so many damn like so many
damn things.
It is pretty cool though to be a to see
what he's been able to get to learn with
like not very much data.
Like just finished up masters.
Feels like stuff's moving fast. Not a
good idea. Is it possible to do
research? It is possible to get into
research without a PhD. Absolutely.
I really genu I don't ever recommend
that people who aren't really sure if
they want to do a PhD to do a PhD like
you do a PhD because you know you want
to do a PhD
setting ads to three men. Uh people
complained more when I did that. So it's
30 seconds
um 30 seconds an hour with some
pre-rolls or 3 minutes an hour with no
pre-rolls.
Someone's money is better spent on cloud
GPU or to buy a physical GPU. It depends
how much stuff you're going to be doing.
At current prices,
you probably just buy like just uh rent
like really cheap GPUs on Vast.
Um cuz the current prices are insane.
If you could actually get stuff at MSRP,
then you buy.
But it's literally like 3x inflated
right now. You can blame Alman for that
web stuff depressed.
Yeah, that would I that would be
depressing. I agree.
This is making me feel like C++ might be
overkill for MEL stuff. What? Have you
seen our source?
It's pure coup to see. Get my guy. It's
pure cud to Hey,
He is way simpler.
Oh yeah.
I agree.
Oh yeah. I agree. Like most people that like are using
Like most people that like are using
C++, they could just be doing their
stuff just fine and see and make less of
a mess of it. I've seen a couple people
write decent C++ where it's like, okay,
fine. But most of the time, h C is just
so easy. I do think C is easy in the
sense it's just so simple.
But easy, it's easy in a good way,
right? Like why make life hard on
yourself?
It's fast. It's really simple. What's
not to like?
Rust. I absolutely despise.
Zigg seems like okay.
If you want a C++ replacement, like Zigg
seems okay,
but it's not a C replacement to me. It's
like way too much.
Like every single C replacement language
ends up changing way too much from C. C
is really good. They're only like a few
kind of jank things
and they're pretty All
rock harness.
Oh my god, everybody just asked me about
the stupid LLM. It's It's just faster
than codeex, guys. It's not that deep.
Okay, it's really not that deep. The
model is faster.
Heck, I got sick of waiting it. I got
sick of it being slow even though it's
still faster. So, you see how fast it's
generating now? I have it on medium.
I just need it to be faster so I cannot
be sitting here waiting. [laughter]
That's kind of sad because it's just not
that hard.
That way when I say English is the next
language,
I don't have I'm not being a myopic
bigot. I'm just being a bigot.
Is it better though? It's better for me
because it's faster and I need it to be
fast.
You actually type the words Malik and
free.
Huh?
Yes.
You Malakan free stuff at C.
Why is everybody afraid of memory
management?
right. This is how to fix this is how
you do me memory management in 10
seconds. Right. When your program
starts, you malic memory need and that's
it. That's all you have to do.
[laughter]
When the program exits, the operating
system frees it. If you have to allocate
something in a loop, then yeah, you have
to free it in the loop. That's it.
You actually don't even have to free
your memory is the funny thing. Like if
it's if it's for the whole lifetime of
the program, you don't have to free it.
I actually made the decision to delete
all the freeze from uh like the main
chunk of the program in Puffer 5 because
there's just no point. Nobody else is
going to call it. It's the main
function.
D is not a good programming language
anymore because in Malakin free, bro,
it's really easy.
No, like you you shouldn't be manag like
you should be managing your memory.
Every other language that tries to do
something fancy with memory management
just makes it more complicated
by hiding the details from you.
It's like oh here you stupid baby.
I know you can't handle memory
management. I know that's too
complicated. Sh. It's okay. The language
will handle the memory management. It's
okay. The language will secretly
allocate the memory for you and secretly
free it and secretly be very low.
Okay,
not bad.
frame thing is we're going to have to
handle the frame thing I'm sure.
It's not bad though
without If you think you need garbage
collection in a language to write
substantial programs, you need to learn
how to program
cuz that's just straight meme.
>> Now we start getting to the vibecoded
end of PRs that are going to be painful.
How bad is this code?
Actually, you know what? Kvert sometimes
vibe codes the crap out of stuff and he
sometimes um he sometimes does stuff by
hand.
Looking at this, I'm guessing this is
vibe coded to hell.
Jeez.
Let's see.
Oh god.
Yeah,
I think he actually ran. He might have
actually run my compression thing on
this.
He said he was going to.
That would be super funny
if he tried to hide the LLM crap by
using my like compression thing.
But you cannot hide from me.
if they make it readable, they're not
vibe coding it.
the thing is I can guarantee you with
this, even though this is better than
some of the other ones, like I guarantee
you that I could cut at least 20% of the
lines off of this file and have it do
the exact same thing and be just as
faster or faster
Um, bet. I'm actually going through and
I'm trying to like prevent like just
trying to avoid any jank like here.
See, like I can see that nothing got
messed up. Pong's good.
The serve thing on Pong I have to figure
out.
No, this is a shitty old like this is
just a shitty old machine that still has
a Windows on it of all things. Um,
this is running in a WSL term making
changes, but then the actual experiments
are being done on an HGPU box remotely
with Abuntu.
Linting does not make stuff readable on
its own. Nope.
Spencer what he's doing with that. I
don't want to change that though because
I know Spencer's using this
burn fire
Been using Vim since high school. It's
good. I used VS Code for like a year cuz
I had to for a thing and hated it.
bots.h.
Okay, that's fine.
Um I there's some stuff I want to clean
up with this, but this will be a bigger
thing and I don't want to screw with
Spencer's work.
So, I think we're fine here.
Rust doesn't actually make your code
safe.
It's also just a awful language.
I wanted to borrow checker. Take out a
loan. Next language.
This is local, but then it does have SSH
access to um a vast box I have rented
for the day.
I actually need to kill that instance
soon.
to music
too distracting. I literally have
Runescape open on the side window.
This is like brain dead work here. This
is basically just what what you're
seeing here is just basic maintenance.
Like all the pre-release work is
essentially janitorial work. All right.
The only reason I don't have two
instances of it open is because I got
logged out with a weird update earlier
today and I didn't bother reopening the
other one. All right. Like,
this is not real work. This is just
annoying maintenance that needs to be
done before the release. I have to do
it,
but whatever.
This is state of the art reinforcement
learning,
but this is like the janitorial work
that you have to do
um for your like for your library. This
is not the cool research bits. Those
bits are much more focused.
um, they have different models. Like,
PyTorch sucks for what we're doing here.
It literally will cap you at onetenth of
the performance that we have.
You really just need your own custom
CUDA C stack. And basically, you'll just
spend so much time in PyTorch chasing
performance that you're never going to
get because it's their library. It's
nothing you're doing. It's the library.
I've gone I did that for like two years
before we went to CUD to C. Um, we tried
every possible thing to keep it in like
a more common framework and it just
wasn't worth it. Ultimately, we had to
do a custom thing.
Okay, we're going to give this this one
some more time. Uh, but not now. I'm not
going to do the 6K line PR evaluation
now. We'll just let um we'll get this
thing integrated and then we'll fix it
later.
I compare puffer liib to
um
trying to think like what's a really
high perf
piece of software that's domain
specific.
No, it's not close to Jax.
Jax is a big heavy framework.
Jax is an ancient what? It's a
relatively newish thing.
It's not comp. It's not clean RL either.
I mean, the closest thing I would like
we use Ray Lib for our graphics. That's
kind of the closest. No, cuz Ray is
still like a more general library.
You know Rayb, we use Rayb for all our
visuals.
who's that puffer fish on the front
page?
That's us.
I was the one who got him to add the
company sponsored like the company
sponsorship slots.
I mean, like, look at this. Yeah. AGI,
my guys. It's AGI. That's how that's how
you zero your data.
It does zero it in the worst way
possible.
This was some sub agent I don't know
doing what. This is why I check it
because like it just adds crap for no
reason.
Step and then a render.
Or render and then step.
step then render?
That doesn't make sense, does it? Cuz
it's reset render
step render step ren. Like it should be
renders first.
Uh, the hugging face stuff they
intentionally blew out of proportion to
generate like to make their model seem
cool and dangerous.
It doesn't matter. Well, it does bet if
it if we're going to use render to
hijack the action loop.
C demo.
Yeah. So, um, bet the cool thing is we
no longer need C file for all of the,
uh, different demos. Like, we literally
just have one demo file.
And you don't even have to write the C's
anymore.
It's pretty nice.
No. So you still have to write yourh
file obviously bet
but like the extra C file you know how
you'd have to write the exact same loop
every single env that's like you know
init the env
like render step render step model
inference that portion you don't have to
write anymore
we just found a way to do that more
cleanly.
without having to write it every file.
Back prop is the best way to we don't
it's the best thing we have.
We don't know whether it's reasonable to
expect something else to be better or
not.
Any reason to use C++? We don't use C++.
This is cudacy.
because they need to compile under a C
compiler.
Um, but they also compile as CUDA.
So you can do one compilation unit with
NVCC.
And then our whole codebase, it's all
incu.
so that we don't need launch wrappers
and we can keep things very tight.
But that doesn't mean it's C++ like
we're just writing C in CUDA files.
Well, of course there's CUDA, right? How
do we train? How do you think we train
our models?
It's actually very tightly optimized
CUDA.
Okay, realistically, how many more M's
do I need to do? 1 2 3 4
8 9 10
12 13 14 15 more m
if I want this to be done tonight. I
have to go faster.
We're still gonna, unfortunately,
tomorrow, we didn't get to the turnbased
stuff. Um, so we'll still have to do
that tomorrow.
Uh dev is on the current 5.0 codebase.
Expect a gigantic merge tomorrow with
all of the uh the new ends.
Tonight we can at least star the puffer
on GitHub. that is free and that helps
me out a lot.
Give star. Thank you very much. Puffers
like stars.
issues is anything good. Uh, our issues
are not
our issues are not really a good place
to start for stuff to do. Frankly,
people kind of just open random issues.
You're way better off just sort of
hanging out in the Discord and picking
up projects and stuff from there.
Most new contributors write ends. It's a
really good way to get into the project.
It's a lot of fun. It you literally just
need like first course in systems level
C. If you actually are relatively
proficient in low-level dev, it'll only
take you a few hours to write your first
env.
How's it 837 for you? 9:37. My bad.
My clock is wrong.
simple assembly. You don't even need to
go that level. That low level, man. It's
like brain dead sea for a lot of the end
code.
I know a lot of the end code is
genuinely very simple.
Now if you want to get into the whole
cuda stack that we have and the trainer
and the architecture and especially the
way our research is, it gets a bit more
complicated but the barrier to entry to
do like something useful is very low. We
actually one contributor made us a
soabon environment that's only a few
hundred lines of code. Um and that ended
up being an amazing research
environment.
We had somebody submit 2048 that ended
up being an amazing research
environment.
220 lines taken out of Afin lock and it
still trans. Yo Kvert, [laughter]
[gasps] you had some slop, my guy.
I literally I didn't even touch it.
That's not even 220 lines taken off with
me like doing anything. That's just me
running the stupid skill file. I'm sure
I could take much more off of it if I
actually tried.
Uh, not yet. Convert. It'll all be I'm
doing one gigantic merge tomorrow.
I'm going to be honest, like I get sick
of well if people submit me clean PRs to
the current branch, I'll just merge
them, but otherwise I kind of just yink
the code and merge it manually.
And if you want to show up on the
contributor list or whatever, you can
just open a PR to the website with your
name
and you'll be on the contributors list.
Yeah, I just don't particularly care
about our PR or our issues list. Like
you can open PRs and if it's useful,
I'll get the stuff from there,
but I don't like I've never been the
type of person where it's like I need to
have zero open issues or I need zero
open PRs. It's kind of like, oh, I need
to have zero unread emails. Like no, I
have 10,000 unread emails. I don't care.
good a really good and useful env. That
is a good question. Okay, so um a good
env typically you should be able to get
nonzero performance on it after only a
little bit of training. Whether that is
because it's scalable in the sense that
there's some easy portion early on or
however you want to set it up. Um we
typically don't need a bunch of new Ms
that you can just train in 3 seconds.
Sometimes that can be cool, but for
research grade M things that we actually
use for um testing whether our algorithm
is better, we like stuff that sort of
scales in problem difficulty.
So uh a really good sign of this is
having like a nice log linear curve with
performance.
So if I can keep spending compute and
keep doing better on the environment and
not saturate that tends to be an
interesting task because that means that
perhaps with some algorithmic changes
you know I can shift the entire curve
upward and that's really easy for us to
measure. Typically at a high level,
environments should introduce some sort
of interesting challenge in some way or
other for the agent. Like 2048, for
instance, doesn't seem like a
particularly interesting task at first.
Like, okay, it's a relatively simple
game. You make 2048, like it's not that
difficult, but then it turns out like
the agent can keep going to 4096, 8192,
16k, 32k. H it can do very very well.
And it turns out that the strategy
required to do that is actually pretty
non-trivial and it scales well with
compute. So that's like one nice
example, right? Um mazes were another
one. We do randomly generated up to n
byn mazes. That's really nice because
you can always increase n to make it
harder. It's a pretty damn good test of
memory and credit assignment. And you
also get to test um you know robustness
under extreme reward sparity as well.
Uh I will say I am not particularly
interested in taking VC money.
It like I don't want the strings.
Also, it's not free money. Like
I I don't really need to give away
equity for that.
I'd rather give equity to people that
actually like build stuff.
Kvert, did you ever send me a sweep
curve for a lock?
See, man, this is the thing. you do lots
and lots of different projects,
but like if you want to design a thing
and you think it's going to be useful
for something, you can totally just like
give me evidence that will immediately
make me like want to use the end
instantly for all of the research. Okay,
look, you have an end that you say
scales in difficulty, right? Those are
really useful for research. How do we
measure that? Scaling with compute,
right? Well, how do we tell that? Well,
we run a sweep on it and then we look at
the PTO curve of performance. We verify
that the points that are up on the
higher end are actually doing something
non-trivial and impressive and that that
behavior is getting better the more
compute you put into it under optimal
hyperparameters that makes an
interesting environment.
So, you know, if you PR the ENV and you
link me like, "Hey, look at this sweep
curve." We get this awesome scaling with
compute or like it plateaus here, but
then it like jumps up here like, you
know, okay, that's interesting.
Yeah. Constellation as well as, you
know, you put a gift for the policy or
something. explain like if it's doing
something non-trivial as well ideally
if it's not obvious like 2048 is a great
example of this right like you can see
it making like 16k on the score after an
hour under optimal hypers and then no
policy that is taking less time will do
that well
and then version after version we're
able to make it take less and less time
to get to that same score and we're able
to push to higher and higher score in
the same time.
I mean, that's like a halfcoherent quote
bet. I'm sure if I wrote it down, I'd be
more eloquent, but I've been streaming
for like 9 hours today, so
Like, if you're going to quote me
directly, like, okay,
if I were gonna like
You're quoting me rambling on stream
though. You're not quoting me like
actually giving you like a a coherent
statement.
Advisor was chill,
but academia as a whole? No.
Oh, wait. No, he didn't. He said he
didn't vibe code the other end.
Uh
the stalt is fine at least.
Couple janky things.
This is one of those where I'd probably
have to spend some real time to um to
clean this up significantly.
Open the eyes. Well, we do have our own
library of environments. It's called
Ocean. We have like 50 of them. Um,
compared to Jim, we are running probably
on average about 10,000 times faster.
So
it kind of becomes a whole different
field at that point.
Yeah. Also, Jim kind of doesn't do
anything. It's just like an API for
environments and then some really,
really bad vectorzation code.
This clean up its macro crap.
Yes,
I can barely see where the if statements
are. Well, I'm looking for specific
things,
right? I like I know the exact types of
things that this is going to screw up
and I'm looking for those. Like here's
one. This is done. This already was
fixed.
a million times faster. Uh million is
there are a couple places where it is a
millionx faster, but that would be an
exaggeration in most cases.
For stuff that is like had any effort to
be made fast, we're typically between
100 and a thousand times faster. But
there are very real cases where we are
like 10,000x faster.
You can literally train Breakout in
under a second. There are libraries, the
common libraries like that have any
version of Breakout. Typically, it's
like a multiple hour problem. There are
a couple ones with custom problems that
have it in like an hour or whatever. We
have it in under a second.
Yes, we do also have business
mostly looking for larger companies at
this point
or startups with budget.
cuz otherwise the small ones take too
much time away from my dev
Bloat.
Avoid obs.
Hang on.
Just check this real quick.
I think we can improve it, but it's not
bad.
Okay.
Wait, let me do it. Yeah, over here.
Yeah,
don't write your code like this.
Don't write your code like this.
The joke. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Don't super
deeply indented code for no reason like
needlessly. Okay, this is correct. You
see, cuz here without the continue, this
is just typical sign of noob code,
right? If instead of this you reverse
this not equal zero, you put this in
here, you just keep indenting and
indenting and indenting
and then you have to start wrapping
lines because the lines get too long.
I will be the first to tell you editor
is really not important. As a guy who's
been using Vim for 15 years,
you can use whatever the hell you want.
I like Vim because I can run it on a
Docker. I can run it on like uh over SSH
and I basically just have my entire
development environment with me wherever
I go which is very minimal anyways
and I don't have to worry about like oh
this plugin to SSH this plugin for
container this like I don't have to care
about anything
and it just always works
you know.
So yeah, editor does not matter.
The exception to this is if you're brand
new to programming and you tell me that,
oh, I use cursor. Like, off with
that. Go write some C by hand.
How many lines did I remove from soccer?
I don't think I removed much of
anything. Kvert, is it 700? Uh, the only
thing I did is I fixed like when I
ported you saw when I had this thing
port Soccer to Puffer 5 or port it to
like the new thing it like it did some
jank across all the ends in the process
of getting stuff to work on the website.
I'm correcting that now. Do you worry
about massive files?
Not worry about Yeah, don't you don't
worry about file size.
course it's a puffer fish. It's puffer
AI. It's their mascot.
Uh
well, I think on Forro you just have to
run the cache data script like the
constellation cache data script. Then
you build constellation and dot sls.
Oh, it did add this.
Thank you.
No, it did not change the puff white. It
changed the position.
I got to now read all three of these.
Hang on.
The thing is there shouldn't be any code
other than them moving something from
one file to the other here.
Uh, did I check Space Invaders? I don't
think I did.
Oh, well, that one's a brand new end, so
whatever.
Your co-workers are opening 20K line
PRs.
And now you understand why I don't work
at shitty companies.
The only like gigantic PRs we've merged
are the um like Vo's Runescape EN
where that's obviously just going to be
massive.
Since when the is Agent
Observations Voidar?
I hate language models, man.
Oh, let's just make the agent
observations void star.
Man, it just slips things by
you every time. Even when you're being
careful is why it's so annoying. It's
very frustrating.
I would never make observations. Void
star.
Something got slipped by me for the last
week. Apparently,
I didn't notice cuz I was just doing the
ends Now,
It's not that it's an include order
issue, man. It's that it did like a
completely fix instead of just
flipping two lines.
You would never make your OBS void star.
That is awful.
I wouldn't be surprised that caused a
significant performance dip.
I don't know how I didn't catch that as
well.
Got to wait for that.
Why would void make it slower?
Compiler doesn't know the type under the
hood.
It very well could disable a bunch of
compiler optimizations.
See, with the macro, if I use obs t, the
macro is defined at compile time, so it
knows it's a float.
system that exists. It's just very slow.
Have you seen like parallels?
Yeah, that exists.
It's just very very slow,
for games it's gotten a lot better at
least.
I don't know how that works. I don't
know how proton works to be fair, but
for game stuff has gotten much better.
I don't know. I've kind of like I've
kind of leaned away from support
everything type stuff
recently.
Hufferlib kind of started as a support
everything in RL project
and then I just sort of realized over
time that everything in RL was kind of
crap and it was literally just better to
build new versions that were good then
were to spend all the time and effort
trying to maintain a crap version that
would never be Good.
To be fair, I don't know what the state
of Unix was back then.
He spoke at Open AI actually and he said
that back then he was just trying to
write good code
like when he started and when news were
really just building building building.
The funny thing is you actually don't
need Windows for games anymore. Like
almost everything runs perfectly on
Linux.
It's pretty much just the big
anti-cheats that don't run on Linux. And
that's because it's like lol kernel
level antiche. How about no?
Yeah, let's do this.
Fine.
Tower defense is going to need a
refactor. I'm not doing that today.
Trash pickup. Let's do the uh the ones
that are like the old ends.
You're playing a video game at the same
time.
Not a competitive game. Just training.
Uh
just have Runescape open on this side.
but by every Saturday. So, I don't
stream every Saturday lately. Um, it
used to be that Saturday would always be
my long stream day where I would stream
like 12 plus hours. I haven't been doing
that lately. I've gotten a little soft.
But I have this weekend off to myself,
so I figured I may as well really crank
on some dev.
I know when I was building Puffer 3 and
parts of Puffer 4, it was like, "Don't
talk to me. It's Saturday.
Time to grind 14 hours of porting from
torch to cuda.
MIT good for views.
What? Like sticking MIT whatever in the
title. I don't want to do that. That's
shitty.
Why does it matter if it's a Saturday?
That's the funny part. It literally
doesn't cuz I make my own schedule, but
I do it anyways.
Wait, literally just three new M's and
one of them I know is fine.
Oh, we just have three new M's after
this and I can go to sleep.
Why do we have 30 people watching me at
10:25 p.m. on a Saturday night?
What are you all doing?
Oh, actually X fixed their view count.
You actually get a correct view count
from X now. That's fun.
Well, if any of you are new around here,
Star Puffer on GitHub. It helps us out a
lot. It is free.
If you want to help even more,
build a cool RLN [snorts] and PR it to
puffer.
That is for going deep in ML.
I mean, if you read my article, right,
couple of my articles, the R the RL
guide basically walks you through like
look, you read this and you read this,
then you build a uh build a little
puffer
and then you read this. It walks you
through quite nicely.
It's not like a learn RL in five minutes
thing obviously,
but it's also not a learn RL in five
years thing. Like you can make good
progress over a weekend.
If you're if uh if you submit obviously
vibecoded crap, I will not give it a
serious review.
Please note,
I will flame you for it, though.
I do not hold myself to any sort of
professional conduct standard on stream.
That would be exhausting.
Where has puffer helped teams?
Where has Puffer helped teams the most
so far in training?
Uh, I mean, we have a bunch of different
application areas. It's not just like
all our contracts are in one area,
but like the general type of problem is
where either there is a fast sim or we
can build a fast sim.
And that does include places where you
would not expect us to be able to build
a fast sim. We're very good at it.
Can anything cool happen?
How much compute does that have? You can
probably deploy policies on it, like
tiny ones. Some of our policies you can
basically run on a potato.
It's got a Wi-Fi chip. Uh, you can run
on device
most likely
if you can load like can you load 10k
par how much how much RAM does it have?
Like is 10,000 parameters too much? I
think probably 10,000 parameters is
about the minimum to do something with
puffer.
did anyone actually fix that Weston did.
Apparently,
if I pull his PR, I kind of like it
being crap though because this was
Spencer's first environment PR
and the code is total
Um, and now Spencer kicks ass.
4 MB flash, dude. That's plenty.
4 MB flash. Like, you can deploy like a
500k parameter model on that, no
problem.
That thing's overkill if anything.
Deploy 4 megabytes.
What? Our models are smaller than that,
dude.
How big did you think our models were?
Like what, dude? Here,
I'm going to show you the lazy version
of this.
God damn it.
Hang on a second
here. Let me show you. This is not
Python garbage stream, my guy.
I know it's hard to tell because you see
me doing really stupid maintenance work
just typing crap into Grock,
but um there.
All right. Hopefully this has reasonable
defaults on it. How long do you think it
takes to train Breakout?
900 ms.
And uh if you check this out on our
website,
you'll get a policy that basically plays
Breakout perfectly.
And how many how much Breakout do you
think this think this thing played?
60 million frames of Breakout. Actually,
more because it's multiplied by frame
skip.
So
hang on.
Okay, so 180 million frames. So divide
that by 60 fps and I don't know, that's
a whole bunch of breakout.
What the are AI labs doing? Now you
know why I'm not at one of them.
I got other things to do.
And uh that breakout env is like a few
hundred lines of code. Uh if you've ever
taken an intro systems course, like
you've ever seen C at all, you can write
that environment.
Okay, you can write the CPU version, not
the GPU one. The GPU one is just a
shitty vibe port. Anyways, the uh the
CPU one is decent. There's a few hundred
lines of super basic C.
Obviously, the rest of the infra is way
more complicated around it, but it's
still pretty short. It's only 5k lines.
No, they're just training really big
models is all. And infrastructure is not
optimized for small models. That's why
we wrote our own.
dude like it. This is not hard. Here,
look. This is a minimal environment. All
right, this is a minimal multi- aent RL
environment. It's 134 lines of code.
Ready? I'm going to walk you through
this. It's uh most of our M's are not
compacted like this. I compacted this
one a little bit so it would fit on one
screenshot. Okay, so we have some
constants. We have a clip function. We
have a log strct. We have an entity
strct. We have an environment strct that
has a log. It has an array of agents and
has an array of entities. That's it.
Okay, here's some that uh the
LLM added. We're going to delete this.
This is puffing it. You set the number
of agents. You zero some variables.
I'm pretty sure the LLM added this
as well to be honest with you.
What the even is this?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure we can just delete
this crap. But I don't want to risk it
now. I'll fix this in the morning. Um,
this is the log function. You just call
dict set on a couple things, whatever.
Here's the observation computation. This
is the most important part. You walk
through some agents. You compute the
heading and speed of your own agent. And
then you walk through the other agents
and you compute their relative distance
to you as well as a cool down and a
type. That's it.
Here's your reset function. You just
randomize the positions of everything.
Here's the step function. You walk
through all of the agents. You move
them. If they hit a target that's not on
cooldown, you put it on cool down and
you advance the target. Here's your
reward. You get a one for hitting the
target. Here's some logging. That's it.
Here's the target like post computation
stuff. Here's your rendering function.
It's like 20 lines of ray, not even.
And here's close. That's the entire n.
So the barrier to entry is quite low.
Skill ceiling is very high, but the
barrier to entry is quite Oh,
LAR.
Liidar sort of works. It's slow
like LAR based SIMs. Uh actually GPU
drive. We have the highest perf
self-driving sim with uh NYU.
It sort of has lidarish.
It's kind of annoying.
This is good enough for government at
work for the day.
Why isn't there a way to make a stuff
CUDA? There is.
Oh, on ARM. No, on AMD there is.
But like if you if you're worried about
not having a GPU, you can literally rent
a decent GPU on VAS for 10 cents.
like 10 cents an hour. It's not
expensive.
Running some of our experiments is a
little bit more expensive because we run
a lot of experiments. But if you just
want to be able to play around a little
bit and like build a little env and
train it, 10 cents an hour for a GPU.
Python type and functional programming
and test driven. Oh, in my intro guide,
uh, let me give you a proper answer that
that hang on.
So,
Python is not a fast language. It's a
very slow language. Um, why do people
write Python? People write Python
because it's very compact. It's a very
succinct language. You really don't have
to worry about many of the underlying
details of anything and it just runs.
Okay. So the type hint system
you kind of just sacrifice a bunch of
that
and normally
strongly typed languages in return for
being fast uh in return for you doing
that are faster right
but in the case of Python it's not
faster
it's just annoying
in fact in some cases It's actually
slower.
Functional programming is a weird dogma
like object-oriented programming where
it's imposing a very strict way of doing
stuff on all of your work that is
fundamentally incompatible with how a
computer works because computers have
shared mutable memory and that's how you
make things fast.
It's mostly weird math nerds that get
into functional. I don't understand why.
Um,
and TDD assumes that you can anticipate
exactly what the hell it is that you're
building and the shape that it's going
to take where you never can.
So, it assumes the conclusion
and the benefit that it's supposed to
give you is stability or whatever. Some
of the worst code bases I've seen are
the most heavily tested.
You can write some tests, but making
testing the focus of your entire
development makes no sense.
Those would be the brief versions of it.
Nvidia stuff runs. Yeah. So, Nvidia does
only run GPU. Are tests bad?
Um, tests are not bad. Maintaining a
ton of tests is bad.
I typically treat most of our tests as
throwaways.
We'll like write some stuff. Sometimes
we'll have a really important test that
we keep around, especially like kernel
performance tests or stuff,
but most tests are considered throwaway
because having a bunch of tests prevents
you from actually fixing your problem,
which in most cases means like actually
refactoring the thing into something
better.
Test lock you into a design
test whatever the hell you want.
But I never yell at people for like you
didn't write tests, right? I yell at
people if it's like, "Hey, this code's a
broken mess. Did you even did
you even test it?" Doesn't mean did you
even write a test. It means like did you
run the code? Did you run it with a few
of the normal arguments like does the
like does it work under normal
conditions even
and even then bugs are like in well good
code like bugs are okay whatever we fix
them.
I'm way happier just fixing a few bugs
than I am dealing with horribly
designed, bloated crap.
That's not bad. Hey, this one's actually
clever. Look at this.
That's actually kind of clever the way
that this is done. I respect this.
You got way too many strugs though for
an end this simple
This is cool.
Wait, is this recursive?
Yeah, it's not recursive. Good.
See, this is even done correctly.
I was like, oh no, it's going to be
shitty recursive. But it's not. He did
it correctly.
ref Frontier Cell.
This I don't understand
and I'm not going to at this hour.
three channels. H
I don't know how I feel about that. That
might be okay.
What
dynamic pro? No,
I was just looking whether the
implementation was recursive.
You don't need the implementation to be
recursive even if it's like a DFS.
Is that how you implement a flood fail?
Is it not just like a BFS? Pretty
Now we're getting into the territory
where I start suspecting bloat.
Okay, this is non-trivial for me to
figure out how bloated stuff is.
Um,
but I am pretty confident that at least
I did not introduce any more bloat to
this in my patching.
So, I'm probably going to add this to
the list of M's that I try to refactor
for release if it's good.
I just have to make sure it didn't break
our nice end.
I should commit all of this so I don't
lose it.
Berkeley, Caltech, a few others in Cali.
Keltech is cool.
35,000 insertions,
6,900 deletions.
I don't know how re uh resources got
into here.
I'm going to push this for now. I'm not
going to push the core changes yet.
But I'm going to push all the end
changes because those are the ones that
are annoying to uh to replicate
you don't even need a Docker for our
stuff honestly. You do need a working
CUDA setup though which typically people
just get Nvidia's Docker image so they
don't have to set up um CUDA dev tools.
Whatever though.
Okay,
that was a lot.
Like 9 hours stream today or something.
We have more to do tomorrow.
Um, hang on. Where's Where's my stream
window?
All right. So, we have more to do
tomorrow.
We got pretty much all the M's settled.
There's some rendering stuff I want to
fix with turn-based ends.
There are some additional checks,
the 500 lines of bloat that have crept
into here, mostly onto the CPU eval. I
don't even know what this is.
Basically, nothing else should have been
screwed with. Yeah, this is still about
the same. So, pretty much all the bloat
just went right into here.
That's easy enough to fix.
So, we'll sort this out tomorrow
and then hopefully we should have
pre-release by Monday.
Uh, bet we already have that set up. Oh,
you know, there's one last thing I need
to do tonight.
You're using medium cuz it's faster.
Stir.
This is fine. It's This is fine. If
something is like 10x faster, I'll try
that. And no, not the open AI one.
That's going to be a bajillion dollars.
Yeah, I can take the vast instance down.
Oh man.
which doesn't do they seriously censor
that in chat?
Okay, we're going to call this a day.
Thank you very much everyone for tuning
in.
We'll be back tomorrow.
I'm going to try to get the rest of this
release done.
Yeah, thank y'all. Start the puffer on
GitHub. Join discord.gg/puffer
if you're interested. I'm going to get
some